i did want to ask you about your last
frame of the movie and
i mean i don't even know where to start
with asking about that
so much is on your shoulders in that
moment how do you even prepare for
something like that what kind of
conversations do you have to have with
chaka in order to just feel supported
in a moment like that well we we i think
instinctively spiritually we all knew
that that this was this was taxing
on the soul it wasn't something that was
just oh we're actors we're just gonna do
we all
i think even going around the table from
the very beginning with it with the
with the hampton family it's like like
uh
we got to know everybody's heart and
everybody's truths
from the very beginning why we each
wanted to do it so we knew it was bigger
than
just us wanting to act so now if we knew
that we were giving our souls to this if
i know that daniel's giving his soul to
this and he knows that i'm giving my
soul to this how do we
show up for each other in that way how
do we lend ourselves
in the best way possible to each other
and i think you know in the cast we you
know we went bowling
we were roller skating we found moments
to really share
time and space with each other i
remember there was one day where we
weren't even
on set it was daniel myself and la keith
and um i believe like ian and caleb we
were all
not filming that day but algae was on
sad shock at everybody else
and we was like um i think lakeif
ordained was like you want to go to set
so we drove to set and i remember
shaking kind of got emotional about that
because
actors don't do that we're just so much
we could be resting we could be
preparing for the next day but we just
always gravitated and was around each
other
and i think that's like the spirit of
chairman fred and his black panther
party that he was able to create in the
illinois chapter
right and so um we definitely held space
for each other the day before
we actually filmed on the 50th
anniversary of the assassination of fred
hampton
and so that of chairman fred and um and
that was
that was something in itself it was we
didn't even have to have words it was
spiritual you know um it was actually
the day that
o'neill actually does his judas like
thing gesture was the day that we filmed
that actual
scene so that was definitely intense and
then
the night before i remember being in my
hotel room and like i was so
emotional and i didn't understand why my
body
was reacting the way that it was it was
in knots my heart was pounding so i had
my throat was tight
i felt like i wanted to cry and i didn't
know why and i kept saying danny's gonna
be okay i think it's gonna be okay like
and i realized that my body did not know
how to separate
and um which is a it's a big
it's a small price to play pay in order
to
to give your alter a role which is what
i asked for from the very beginning how
do i get
to the point where i could love somebody
so much that the sacrificial gesture she
does in the end
is believable how do i get to that point
just opening my spirit how do i love in
that way
watching danny take up space watching
disney have dimples like watching how he
moves and i'm really internalizing every
single thing so by the end
we were coming to the end of the film we
were coming to the end of the life of
chairman fred and the end of the love
that him and
deborah johnson got to share together
and so i had to lose it too
you know even though daniel and i and my
cast and i will love each other for
for the rest of our lives and beyond
like we're
we were only we were only fortunate to
get a little bit
a little bit of time inhabiting that
kind of love because that love is
transformative that love is
un unconditional at the core you know
true definition of unconditional love
was there and
uh you know and so to get a little taste
to be able to experience that i had to
love and then lose and so i had to let
myself cry
in that um in that hotel room the day
before and
it was very quiet that other day and you
know having to be on top of him while
everything was happening that was also
intense because we had the bullets we
had the
you know seeing the bloody the other
room and seeing my friends my
castmates my family now uh be
shot up like you know what i mean like
that is it's traumatic you know and
and i had um i had actually in my
personal life had seen something
like that happen you know so the sound
of gunshots
is not foreign to me it's somewhere
deep in my psyche and my my spirit and
so
to be there and hear those things was
actually traumatic
again like it was so many levels and i
remember mama cool just saying she did
not cry
she did not cry when they assassinated
him in cold blood she did not cry
and i think underneath that was was the
power
of like i'm not gonna give them
satisfaction she said that they were
laughing
they were carrying his body out and
chanting chairman fred is dead
chairman fred is dead so they were happy
and they were singing about that so for
her
no i am not going to cry i will not give
them the satisfaction
that was very important and then also i
mean even for me i had to wrap my
head around getting off of him you know
how if he he
he's been drugged he's still alive but
he cannot wake up
do i move my body off of his if i don't
move my body off of his they're going to
kill me
and essentially they're going to kill
this baby if chairman is all about the
people
is the party about me or is it about the
people then i know
it's about the people and that includes
his son so that was the only way that i
could wrap my head around
getting off of his body is because he
would have said
this is about the people and his people
includes his son
i have to surrender i have to live
so that his legacy can live so that this
being inside can live
you know and uh yeah so it was it was a
lot it was a lot going on